it's will here with mate tom
on their way to wembley but not quite as
it might have been
kobit has changed our plans a little bit
i think probably would have got the
train down but
i think car does feel safer
england fans will and dom drove from
harrogate
nervous of their team's chances but also
of the crowds
definitely slight tweaks due to pandemic
but overall um i think
hopefully you know should feel
like normal times wearing masks in
different ways which again i'm more than
happy to do i think
again that feels it feels like a safe
thing to do
more than 60 000 fans and little social
distancing
the gatherings outside the stadium
offered the biggest potential risk
of covet infection it's not so much the
stadium
we find that these are well managed and
well planned uh regulated numbers
coming in and covered checks it's all of
the fan zones there's going to be an
enormous
celebration and that's when people start
to forget
about the precautions that should still
be in place
police said they would enforce the covid
laws proportionately
police reminded fans that london was
still in a public health crisis
and urged them to stay apart and not
gather
in large numbers fat chance of that
the nhs encouraged fans to pop into the
nearby vaccination center
and get jabbed will tried to do the
right thing
he'd already had one jab but was too
early for his second
they said has to be eight weeks between
the first and the second job and
unfortunately about five weeks
how disappointed uh i'm quite
disappointed i was thinking today you
know especially a big event like this to
hopefully get you know the door
protection and i think you know
especially with rising cases it seemed
like probably a sensible thing to do
so yeah it's a shame but i understand
they're the guidelines
amid the football fever life went on for
non-fans
some were worried about catching covid
sixty thousand fans not socially
distances i know i've just walked
through them all
how concerned are you um well
i'm double jab so that's all right
might have a problem i'm not worried at
all you're not okay
no no it's just one of those things
you've got to learn to live with it huh
it's a huge problem at the moment i i
saw the the coyotes outside
so i think people should be very careful
about it
[Music]
when scotland played here 1300 scottish
fans caught
covid english and italian fans are
hoping
they take home nothing more than
memories of an incredible day
[Music]
martin brunt sky news wembley